You push the same button to automatically put it down.
So this umbrella is amazing because with one button it opens.
It's triple reinforced.
The supports have triple bars so it's not going anywhere in the wind.
And the best part?
You push the same button to automatically put it down.
Other umbrellas with this technology are like 80 $90.
This one on the TikTok Shop $13.
Check if you have coupons cause there's always deals. This umbrella
with the hook to easily just attach it to anything
is absolutely worth it. It's linked right here if you wanna get one.
I don't know if it rains where you live,
but it rains where I live and I very much need an umbrella
and this one is perfect.